i'm a survivor of fgm i was circumcised
twice i decide to work with young people
to educate about fgm
control discrimination available
personally i committed to this fight
because i had worked in northern ghana
in an area where
fgm is practiced and i told myself it
could have been me
i could have been born there and i would
have been helpless professionals need to
know more about fgm so they can protect
a woman i remember first time when i
came to ireland
i was asked what fdm was and i have to
go and do medical checkup and the nurses
did not understand where i come from and
what i was talking about female gender
mutilation is a problem in europe today
because it's a human rights violation
and it's one of the most intimate of
human rights violation
and very often uh women and girls who
are affected do not have the necessary
support
and services that they require in order
to enable them to live a healthy
and adequate life
is
feminine
you